indépendance autonomie stratégique
souveraineté européenne ce sont trois
concept relativement proches les uns des
autres dans l'acception française c'est
très lié aux questions de défense mais
en réalité ça va bien au delà parce que
l'union européenne doit lutter contre
les dépendances quelle qu'elle soit nous
considérons que nous devons faire appel
à trois axes le premier axe est autour
de la question institutionnelle
il faut doter l'union tes moyens de son
ambition d'abord en terme de gouvernance
et c'est la question de la majorité
qualifiée c'est à dire être en capacité
d'agir de manière plus souple c'est la
question aussi du renforcement des
coopérations renforcées par ce qu'il
nous faut pouvoir agir sur tous les
sujets et puis enfin c'est la question
du financement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
demandons la pérennisation de
l'instrument financier et de la
mutualisation des dettes comme une
deuxième axe c'est la question du
soutien à nos entreprises à travers
l'innovation et la régulation c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous appelons de
nos voeux la constitution d'un marché
financier européen aujourd'hui ce sont
27 marchés financiers donc cette
fragmentation a un impact sur le
financement de nos entreprises il faut y
remédier deuxième proposition c'est la
question de la darpa européenne nous
appelons de nos voeux l'équivalent
américain de la darpa pour financer
l'innovation pour soutenir nos
entreprises est troisième et dernier
volet c'est la lutte contre les
ingérences étrangères notamment à
travers l'interdiction d'un certain
nombre d'investissements dans les
secteurs critiques ou encore la mise en
place de l'instrument anti coercition la
convergence des points de vue est en
cours au sein des pays l'union
européenne la présidence française va
pouvoir faire avancer ces sujets